WHERE THEY STAND AND IT COULD
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DEMOCRATS KEEPING CONTROL OF
CONGRESS OR NOT.
>> Reporter: YOU WOULD THINK A
CONGRESSWOMAN IN OFFICE NEARLY
40 YEARS WOULD ALREADY KNOW MOST
OF THE PEOPLE HERE AT THE
POPULAR 818 CLUB.
>> ARE YOU A REGULAR?
>> Reporter: BUT IT'S NEW GROUND
FOR MARCIE CAPTOR WHOSE DISTRICT
CHANGED AFTER REDISTRICTING
GOING FROM A SAFE DEMOCRATIC
SEAT TO A PLACE DONALD TRUMP
WOULD HAVE WON IN 2020.
>> YOU ARE ONE OF THE FEW
DEMOCRATS I WOULD VOTE FOR.
>> Reporter: FOR CAPTOR BEING A
GRAND NAME IN NORTHERN OHIO
HELPS, BUT SHE IS STILL A
MIDWESTERN DEMOCRAT IN A PARTY
INCREASINGLY RUN ON THE COASTS.
>> DOES YOUR NATIONAL PARTY
UNDERSTAND DEMOCRATS YOU
REPRESENT?
>> IT'S HARDER FOR US.
WHAT THE COASTAL PEOPLE, GOD
BLESS THEM, DON'T UNDERSTAND IS
THAT WE LOST OUR MIDDLE CLASS.
WE LOST SO MANY PEOPLE WHO
WORKED HARD ALL THEIR LIVES,
INCLUDING IN MANY OF THESE SMALL
TOWNS.
>> Reporter: WHETHER CAPTOR WINS
THIS NEW BATTLEGROUND DISTRICT
WILL DETERMINE WHETHER DEMOCRATS
KEEP CONTROL OF CONGRESS OR HOW
STEEP THE LOSSES COULD BE.
SHE'S RELYING ON VOTERS LIKE
JOE.
>> I'M IN THE SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL 33 TOLEDO
DISTRICT.
>> Reporter: A UNION THAT
ENDORSED REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
MIKE DeWINE AND KAPTUR.
HIS TOP ISSUE THIS ELECTION
YEAR.
>> THIS TIME AROUND IT WOULD BE
WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
>> REALLY?
>> YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT MATTERS TO ME IS THAT IT'S
YOUR DECISION TO MAKE.
THAT PERSON -- THAT WOMAN'S
DECISION TO MAKE, NOBODY ELSE'S.
>> Reporter: THESE MEN GATHER
MOST MORNINGS AT BUD'S
RESTAURANT IN DDEFIANCE.
A MARCIE KAPTUR SOMEBODY YOU
WILL VOTE FOR?
>> NO.
NO WAY.
>> Reporter: JOE IS VOTING FOR
KAPTUR'S REPUBLICAN CHALLENGER,
ENDORSED BY FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO WIN.
>> Reporter: TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT
IS A --
>> MEANS A LOT TO ME.
I LIKE TRUMP.
>> Reporter: THAT'S
CONTROVERSIAL, EVEN HERE.
>> HE TRIED TO OVERTHROW OUR
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE AND YOU GUYS CAN'T SEE IT.
I'M SORRY.
>> Reporter: MAJEWSKI IS AN
ELECTION DENIER WHO WAS AT THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th THOUGH HE
INSISTS HE LEFT WHEN, QUOTE, IT
GOT UGLY.
>> Reporter: IS THAT A DEAL
BREAKER?
>> FOR ME I WOULD NEVER VOTE FOR
HIM.
NOT FOR ANY OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WERE THERE ON JANUARY 6th.
>> Reporter: NOT A DEAL BREAKER
FOR EVERYONE.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD
INFLUENCE ME TO VOTE AGAINST
HIM.
>> Reporter: CNN'S K FILE
UNEARTHED EVIDENCE MAJEWSKI
REPEATEDLY PROMOTED QANON
CONSPIRACIES, HAS SINCE DENIED
BEING A FOLLOWER.
SETH ISN'T SURE ABOUT HIM YET.
>> I WANT TO SEE HOW HE WOULD
IMPROVE THE AREA, HOW HE WOULD
DO IN CONGRESS.
>> Reporter: THROUGH A SPOKESMAN
MAJEWSKI DECLINED AN INTERVIEW.
THESE MIDWESTERN VOTERS ARE DOWN
ON DEMOCRATS IN WASHINGTON.
>> BIDEN HAS GOT THIS COUNTRY,
AFGHANISTAN, THE BORDER,
INFLATION --
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO SEPARATE
THEMSELVES IT SEEMS LIKE FROM
BIDEN AT THIS POINT.
THEY SAY -- THEY SAY THAT IN
THEIR ADVERTISEMENTS.
>> MARCIE KAPTUR, SHE DOESN'T
WORK FOR JOE BIDEN, SHE WORKS
FOR YOU.
>> Reporter: YOU DON'T BUY IT?
>> I DON'T BUY IT AT ALL.
>> Reporter: MOST HERE SAY
KAPTUR, THE LONGEST-SERVING
WOMAN IN THE HISTORY OF THE
HOUSE WHO WOULD BREAK THAT
RECORD FOR ALL OF CONGRESS IF
SHE WINS HAS BEEN THERE LONG
ENOUGH.
>> NOT THAT SHE'S NOT A GOOD
PERSON IT'S JUST THAT I THINK
SHE'S BEEN IN OFFICE LONG
ENOUGH.
>> WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE?
>> MY RESPONSE IS WHEN YOU COME
FROM THIS PART OF THE COUNTRY
ALL YOU HAVE IS YOUR SENIORITY.
WHEN YOU GET THERE YOU'RE
OUTNUMBERED AND YOU DON'T HAVE
THE GAVEL.
IT TAKES LONGER TO ACHIEVE
SOMETHING.
>> Reporter: STILL, DISGUST WITH
DIVIDED POLITICAL DISCOURSE RUNS
DEEP.
>> I LONG FOR THE DAYS WHEN WE
USED TO SIT IN A COFFEE SHOP OR
THE CIGAR SHOP AND WE WOULD
DEBATE THE ISSUES AND THEN WE
WOULD ALL LAUGH AND BE FRIENDS
AT THE END OF THE NIGHT.
>> Reporter: IT DOES STILL
HAPPEN HERE AT BUD'S.
IN APTLY NAMED DEFIANCE.
>> DANA JOINS US NOW.
IT WAS SO FASCINATING TO HEAR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS, A TOP ISSUE FOR
A REPUBLICAN VOTING SHEET
METALWORKER, BUT I KNOW AS
YOU'VE BEEN TRAVELING AND GOING
TO DISTRICT AFTER DISTRICT,
YOU'VE BEEN HEARING THIS.
>> I REALLY HAVE BEEN.
IT IS OVER AND OVER A TOP ISSUE
FOR VOTERS.
YOU COULD PROBABLY NOT SEE THE
LOOK OF SURPRISE ON MY FACE
BECAUSE OF ALL THE PPE I WAS
WEARING AT THAT CONSTRUCTION
SITE, BUT, YEAH, TO HEAR KIND OF
A BURLEY GUY, MARRIED WITH GROWN
CHILDREN, TELL ME -- I JUST
ASKED GENERALLY WHAT'S YOUR TOP
ISSUE?
HE SAID ABORTION.
AND I SAID